und wir gehen hart rein denn in diesem
moment gibt es einschläge in der nähe
des stadtzentrums von kiew und zwar erst
nachdem die sirenen geheult
beziehungsweise bevor die sirenen
geheult mitgehen live zu paul ronzheimer
paul
thomas wir haben hier drei heftigen
schläge gehört in der nähe des
stadtzentrums es war tatsächlich bei uns
zu spüren hier in der örtlichkeit wo wir
uns befinden die windows haben geschenkt
die windows haben gewackelt sozusagen
und die wende auch also heftigere
einstiege drei waren es insgesamt wir
wissen nicht genau was wo genau passiert
ist aber sind danach sind luft sie den
wieder angegangen und über kiew in einer
situation in der die stadt große sorge
hat was in der nächsten nacht auf sie
zukommen könnte also offenbar eine neue
attacke auf die hauptstadt aus der luft
bescheid ist für uns zumindest aber das
werden wir jetzt noch recherchieren
müssen und es ist so dass das zu einer
zeit wo man davon ausgehen muss dass
russland jetzt wo die nacht wieder an
bericht wo die russische armee einen
weiteren versuch unternehmen wird aus
der luft und mit raketensystem in
richtung hauptstadt zu feuern vor dem
hintergrund paul das eben heute tausende
die möglichkeit hatten kiew zu verlassen
russland hatte einen korridor
eingerichtet
zumindest angekündigt einen einzurichten
daraufhin sind sofort tausende
zehntausende haben sich auf den weg
gemacht und schaut gerade recht nervös
darüber
naja ich habe nur gehört was was da
draußen passiert um zu hören ob wir die
sirenen angegangen sind aber momentan
scheint es ruhig zu sein du sprichst die
zivilisten an diese tiere verlassen
haben das genau der korridor um den es
gegen aber wenn wenn die nacht ein
bericht wirft dann ist eigentlich
niemand mehr auf der straße also die
zivilisten dieses versucht haben
rauszukommen die sind heute morgen früh
als die ausgangssperre aufgehoben war
das waren 8 uhr morgens direkt zum
bahnhof oder auf die straße auf den
highway raus aus ihr
aus dieser möglicherweise dem epizentrum
des krieges zu dem sich die stadt
entwickeln könnte weil blut braucht um
ein sieg verkünden zu können im eigenen
land ohne kers funktioniert das nicht
aber es gibt auch besonderen widerstand
wir erleben dass immer wenn wir hier
über die straße läuft heute da sind
männer mit waffen auf den straßen
teilweise nervös unterwegs kontrolliert
die autos schauen ob es dort russische
provokateure gibt gleichzeitig gibt es
die meldung von vitali klitschko der
gesagt hat russische scharfschützen sind
schon in der stadt damit meint er wagner
soldaten das wurde auch von der sunday
times berichtet die sozusagen auf der
suche sind nach den entscheidenden
leuten den pitch und zählt zu denen
natürlich an platz eins volumina sie
lenze zählt der ukrainische präsident
das wäre für gut hin auch ein sieg wenn
er ihn festnehmen könnte oder wenn deine
truppen den ukrainischen präsidenten
töten würden also viele denkbare
strategien sind möglich was hier kiew
angeht allerdings so das hat die stadt
hier für große sorgen gesorgt ist was in
hartz iv der stadt im osten passiert ist
denn da haben wir heute morgen gesehen
wie die stadt großflächig bombardiert
worden ist mit massiven raketen-
beschuss mit grad das thema offenbar
auch betreut munition sowie experten
sagen und das würde bedeuten dass auch
eine besonders grauenvolle option drin
wäre nämlich die option alle profi
erinnern und da die syrische stadt
bombardiert worden ist von wladimir
putins toten und das ist die angst die
man hier auch in dem fall also
einschläge in kiel für sirenengeheul
wieder in der stadt nachdem man korridor
eröffnet wurde damit menschen die stadt
verlassen können was eben kein zeichen
der hoffnung ist keine gute nachricht
sondern womöglich die vorbereitung auf
eine schlimme nacht auf schlimme stunden
paul ronzheimer danke für den moment wir
sind gleich wieder bei der live in kiew
wir beginnen unsere überblick in kiew
direkt in der hauptstadt und gehen zu
peter hell peter vor wenigen minuten
drei einschläge
kiew festgestellt worden in der nähe des
stadtzentrums
das ist richtig wir standen auch gerade
draußen paul ronzheimer ist ja schon
geschrieben die fenster haben gewackelt
wir haben das auch gemerkt die
detonation waren sehr stark wir wissen
jetzt nicht wahr es jetzt näher am
stadtzentrum dran oder war die
sprengladung höhe ob das jetzt eine 1000
pfund bombe war oder 2005 das wissen wir
nicht das liegt natürlich immer an der
menge aber was danach kam das fand ich
eigentlich persönlich ein bisschen
beunruhigender das war schnelle
abschlüsse wie grad raketen die von
raketen abgeschossen worden sind also
hintereinander abgeschossene raketen die
losgegangen sind auch nicht unweit das
heißt das sind
waffensysteme die sind relativ nahe an
hier am stadtrand da spricht dann dafür
dass die russen dann schon sehr stark
hier angekommen sind das spricht aber
auch leider dafür dass diese
raketensysteme sehr unpräzise sind das
heißt dort wenn man dort seinen gegner
sein feind mit bekämpfen will willmann
fläche machen und in der fläche sind
natürlich auch zivilisten und in so
einem dicht besiedelten gebiet wenn man
mit diesen raketen mit diesen lafetten
in die
fläche schießt da wo vermeintlich
truppen liegen wie auch immer sie gehen
auch dann gerne mal woanders hin und das
ist wirklich die große angst die hier
natürlich im moment ist wenn es denn so
ist wie wir das auch in charkiw gesehen
haben dass da rein geschossen wird dann
und das geht dann auch in die zivilen
häuserreihen und wie in aleppo oder wie
in großen die damals in tschetschenien
wo einfach wahllos mit artillerie mit
grad mit grad-raketen reingeschossen
worden wurde das beinhaltet eine
komplette zerstörung eine
flächendeckende zerstörung und das hat
dann mit militärischen zielen auch wenig
zu tun es ist massenmord im prinzip das
geht komplett gegen die zivilisten weder
die stadt ist wieder komplett verdunkelt
man sieht schemenhaft die kirche hinter
dir am platz du warst heute morgen dabei
und das live berichtete als tausende
wenn nicht zehntausende
versucht haben die stadt zu verlassen
nachdem russland angekündigt hatte dass
ein korridor zur flucht geöffnet werden
sollte das war für viele zunächst mal
ein zeichen der hoffnung aber
tatsächlich ist es eher ein zeichen
dafür dass tatsächlich eine schlimme
nacht und schlimme stunden bevorstehen
könnten denn wenn die menschen die stadt
verlassen sollen dann heißt das nicht
gut ist
auch das ist richtig und wir sind ja
schon einige zeit hier und es ist das
erste mal wo wir so eine art panik hier
bei der bevölkerung mitbekommen haben
die ursprünglich und eigentlich sehr
ruhig war sehr besonnen wo wir uns schon
gewundert haben mein gott bei dieser
bedrohungslage wie locker in
anführungsstrichen die bevölkerung das
hierhin im diesen morgen zur arbeit
gegangen sie haben die sirenen dann mehr
oder weniger befeuert oder sind in den
luftschutzkeller gegangen das wurde so
alles so ein bisschen hingenommen und
jeder hat so gedacht na ja die kennen
diese bedrohungslage schon seit acht
jahren aber was wir heute morgen gesehen
haben ab 8 uhr da ist die ausgangssperre
aufgehoben worden das hatte schon eine
komplett andere qualität sie hatte die
qualität der angst der panik der
orientierungslosigkeit die leute sind
nachdem die russen muss man auch sagen
dankenswerterweise das ist an zynismus
kaum zu überbieten ein korridor frei
geschaufelt haben sind natürlich dann
aufgrund auch der sozialen netzwerke etc
und nachrichtenradio telefoniere rey
sind sie dann zu tausenden zum
hauptbahnhof geströmt und dann ist
wirklich so eine art von panik
ausgebrochen denn dann haben die leute
gesehen oh gott wie viele leute stehen
denn hier standen wirklich zigtausend
auf den bahngleisen es kam nur wenig
züge jeder versuchte ein sitzplatz zu
ergattern rette sich wer kann es gab
dramatische 10 viele familien viele
paare viele einzelpersonen haben einfach
ihre koffer liegen gelassen ihr hab und
gut um eben noch ein rettendes platz in
einem dieser züge zu ergattern
alle züge gehen natürlich nach westen
richtung polen richtung rumänien
richtung moldawien dort wo man eben in
sicherheit ist oder sich in sicherheit
wähnt und wo man dann eventuell auch
dann in das eu land
einwandern kann und diese
hoffnungslosigkeit und auch diese
orientierungslosigkeit die leute wussten
gar nicht wohin sie haben uns gesagt es
ist uns egal wo wir hin wir wollen nur
weg weil wir wissen wenn das denn wahr
es wenn und die russen jetzt uns
anbieten zu verschwinden heißt das
nichts gutes das heißt eigentlich rettet
euer leben oder wird schiessen euch zu
klump auf deutsch gesagt das was sie
schon in aleppo gemacht haben das was
sie auch schon in grosny gemacht haben
das heißt keine rücksicht auf zivilisten
und das haben die leute ja auch gespürt
und deswegen kam es zu diesen sehr
chaotischen dramatischen szenen heute
morgen gesehen während du gesprochen
hatte haben wir die bilder gesehen und
wir sehen sie auch hier toben im kleinen
fenster eingeblendete bilder die du und
ein kameramann gedreht haben heute
morgen es ist schwer natürlich zu
überblicken es waren tausende vielleicht
zehntausende du kannst natürlich nicht
genau sagen wie viele es waren aber wie
muss man sich das vorstellen peter wie
viele menschen sind noch in der stadt
eine stadt von fast drei millionen
einwohner sind die meisten vermutlich
noch da
unfassbar schwer einzuschätzen es ist
halt so jetzt gehen wir sie reden wieder
los das war gerade auch schon also man
merkt die intensität geht los also der
spaß gehört auf jetzt hier die russen
meinen es wirklich ernst heute nach ich
will weiter reden jetzt also die
meisten leute konnten mit dem auto
fliehen dhz werden auto hatte wäre ein
wagen hatte wäre ein bisschen geld hatte
oder wäre vielleicht sogar eine datsche
im westen hatte der konzern aus der ist
auch gestern vorgestern ist er
rausgegangen 50 kilometer lange staus
waren da menschen die heute zum bahnhof
gekommen sind das waren leute von dem
man gesehen hat okay die haben
vielleicht nicht so viel geld wir haben
nicht die möglichkeit mit ihrem auto auf
die datsche zu fahren sondern die müssen
sind auf die züge angewiesen die hatten
wirklich nur ihr hab und gut ist waren
auch ganz ganz viele arbeiter aus dem
ausland die hier gearbeitet haben
pakistan die afghanen bangladesch
menschen die aus asien gekommen sind die
jetzt in panik auch aus kiew geflohen
sind und das ist ein anderer
bitte bitte bring dich in sicherheit
bitte ja wir gehen beginnen direkt
weiter runter zu paul ronzheimer paul
hat um als wir gerade wie peter
natürlich auch die sie leben wieder hier
im stadtzentrum gehört und die stadt die
verbliebenen menschen fragen sich was
kommt jetzt auf sie zu was kommt in
dieser nacht auf sie zu und an szenarien
hat wird auch wieder die reden in diesem
moment in der hauptstand in hier und das
ist die große sorge dass jetzt der große
angefasst ihren konzerten ist und das
sind die luft sie reden die wir in den
vergangenen tagen aber wieder gehört
haben gerade tagsüber ist das teilweise
geisterhaft man hört die sirene dann
dazwischen vogelgezwitscher also das ist
etwas das man sich selbst aber weise
hier mittlerweile auch ihre vorteile was
gewöhnt hat nur jetzt gibt es eben die
sorge dass nach karachi 4 die nächste
attacke auf die nächste große
stadtbilder ukraine passieren könnte
also wir hören einfach mal der serie
dazu moment
das ist die situation die die menschen
die vor allem die zivilisten und hier
jeden tag und gerade in der nacht immer
wieder erleben müssen jetzt bei bild
live sie hören genau in diesem moment zu
wie die luft drehen über hier zu hören
sind gehen sie einmal runter und jetzt
wieder hoch
[Musik]
all das ist absolut gespenstisch und man
mag sich gar nicht vorstellen wie die
situation ist wenn wir das vergleichen
eine stadt eine großstadt fast so viele
einwohner wie in berlin es wäre nach die
ganze stadt ist verdunkelt und die
sirenen würden heulen
also ist es so ist es thoma
jetzt ist die leitung paul ich weiß
nicht ob du mich noch hören kannst das
bild ist gerade eingefroren bringe ich
bitte in sicherheit